i want to have a very big goal that  sounds exciting um but i have absolutely  no emotional investment if i never hit  it i wouldn't be upset i do think i'm  gonna get it but i but i wouldn't be  upset either way can you talk to us  about the how like conceptually kind of  like top level like like how do you plan  to get there we're just going to be  investing in businesses that are similar  the ones that we scaled um and  participate in the growth it's very  simple model  thesismindacquisition.com is i want to  find the people who are the best at  their specific thing the best salon girl  the best autumn you know auto mechanic  the best gym owner the best all of these  things and then wrap the model that i  already know how to deliver  you know provide exceptional service  provide great value how to teach  effectively so that people can  understand the concepts and then  ultimately make a lot of profit and then  participate in that process